I feel like that's what reactors have to
do to save YouTube bond a bond together
the anomalous force here yes the
Pennywise of waning at yeah the
penniless you tubers worst fear is
coming true
hello families
I'm Greg Alba hi I'm John Humphrey in a
moccasin ah Kisan is here the black man
from Japan noodle scooter like I assume
I am the black man from California me
too
we are the black men from California
John now I mm-hmm you might have heard
of before go check out his channel he
has reactions you might be familiar with
the format just a little bit patron of
the day shout out after the reaction for
JT keep a look out this video got sent
to me by a lot of people it is the name
of the movie
it-it-it who's on first yeah what know
what's on second okay we're now
officially actually confusing ourselves
these secrets all your beers I think
this is a behind this law John are gonna
go watch this on Thursday oh god that
Jeff Jones turn up the volume a little
bit pump up the volume you know like
scary movies I think this is behind the
scenes okay so like just be like cool
coverage your king
universe halls aren't you one day you
realize that's not sure it did the story
of a bunch of kids might wake up to
something terrible happening
[Music]
can't wait till he kills that boy
[Music]
they're using a tongue that is quite
unsettling kids there's not like
[Music]
everyone knows that there's something
wrong about this whole situation
my grandfather takes his times cursed
that all the bad things that happen in
this town are because of one thing
every 27 years and more kids disappear I
saw so it turns out that all the murders
and area of the missing children are all
connected look it's all connected by the
sewers as far it was
yeah
[Applause]
whoa-ah
[Music]
entity that is pain loss focuses on
whatever that particular child fears the
most
is anything that you are ever afraid of
it's definitely overcoming that fear and
we do it because work with each other
hang out with us play so those are two I
can take that that really bonds together
because we really have no US Attorney
there's no one else who really cares for
us this kids finding strength I can
being together this is very emotional
and it's terrifying
I had hopes but I was not prepared for
how good it really was
I'm sure my fans will really enjoy the
movie
you got me 500 the original Pennywise is
actually in that shot yeah yeah yeah I
actually did get some different things
from hearing this behind the scenes ah
Kisan it's okay this only happens every
27 years maybe this is like I'm gonna
just start standing up the first one was
in the 50s this one's in the 80s so
maybe this is like some secret
technically sound like I'm a big
technical person the cinematography and
sound and even though I don't like scary
movies I can tell this one has a lot of
work put into it like you're saying
there's some good cuts there's some nice
sound that the disturbing sound that
really makes you like yes feel it yeah
in terms of what they're talking about
here I like that they were capitalizing
on some things that people who haven't
seen the original it movie then the
miniseries or read the books might not
be aware of it's how it's more than just
kids versus a clown yeah it really is
about fears whatever you fear this
demons conjures it up Eddy it offering
up talks to you in the form of a clown
which is the Pennywise clown and the
other thing too that I appreciate what I
got from this was they were the director
was saying how this film is terrifying
but yet it's also emotional sure and one
thing I I don't really feel wise when I
saw the miniseries I got all the context
like I was like okay y'all the kids
banding together and that's like the
whole point is that they work together
but it felt like cheesy and corny like
the entirety of the miniseries look here
I feel like I might actually be affected
and move
yeah by these kids bonding together I've
never read the book but having read
enough you know think pieces about it
especially in lead-up to this movie one
thing I've always gotten the sense of is
that the book is personal and more you
know emotional especially you know when
you come back to them as adults and
stuff that was one thing that drove this
home for me because this kind of felt
like a trailer just with like a couple
snippets of behind-the-scenes yeah but
didn't you strike me so much as being
behind the scenes as just people kind of
talking a little about the movie yeah
just like here's what the director and
Stephen King wants you to think about
you know going into this and that's the
thing that makes me most excited because
that's what I think could deliver on the
terrifying movie everybody keeps saying
it is we were just doing a reaction to
reboots that may not make it are
destined to fail I haven't really seen
anybody say like [ __ ] this movie don't
make it it seems like everybody that
really has been attached to the original
miniseries it's also like yeah we want
to see this it looks good yeah I haven't
heard anybody outright say this they
shouldn't have even bothered making it
at first people were worried and then
they saw an image of the clown and they
were like I saw the first trailer they
were like we're not worried yeah yeah
this looks amazing it's been on an
interesting journey and I've seen like
people releasing early statements about
it online like big-time critics and
they've been saying the film is
fantastic so alright here seeing it this
Thursday sitting Marty North Hollywood
only we have with us I feel a watch meet
and greet a meeting greet for five
minutes as I tend to run like Oh before
we wrap up this video
JT patron of the day shout-out goes out
to this guy he loves the channel and
he's a peach front eject today Jethro
Tull yeah what's his name Justin
Timberlake just never like Jesus Christ
bringing sexy back bringing sexy yep
Josh Tillman what do you think JT stands
for jet turbine jet fan tours Jim
Caviezel Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Jack
teacher
just take we're not getting better
yeah yeah Jewish Trinity Jumbotron
to you Jumbotron subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification belt
that John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram patreon.com slash some real
rejects become a patron eject today
Akasaka saw that way that i've no naka
psalm for many years i've met up with
him in person three times in my life and
he still jacks up my name every time
christen a case Ain a prison ak-47 call
me mr. red mr. red there you go mr.
drebber and redmond the read read it one
Oh Jackie could